السلام
عليكم من
قدوتي شكون قدوتي لا شك كان الرسول صلى
الله عليه وسلم هو المثال الاعلى لانسان
المسلم يا غير القدوه اللي نتكلم عنها هي
القدوه من بلدي من وطني من مدينتي من
محيطي يا نوصل رسالتي ل نشارك معكم قصه
شخصيه وتنطبق على اي شاب في الفئه العمريه
اللي فيها انا تقريبا القصه بطلها
والدي زمن والدي قديما كان كان من الناس
البدو الناس الرحل الناس العايشه في
البديه كانت لقمه العيش عندهم على حساب
روس من الغنم قطعه من البل والله احيانا
من تعود فتره الحصاد والي هي شبه ناذ في
هذ المناطق الصحراويه او احيانا يسافروا
مئات الكيلومترات
شور بلايس اللي يجبر فيها
مرع الحيه اللي
عنده من بعد ذاك شت الاقدار وظهرت ظاهره
التمدن والتحضر وانتقل للمدينه منين
تعرفوا انتم عن المدينه تبدل العموله فم
تعود الفلوس ولا النقود اذا هو كون المعير
الثاني الاسره لان هو الكبير في خوته اذا
ده المعيل الثاني
عاقب خص يف خص يجيب الفلوس اذا مرق يخدم
هو صغير 13 سنه ولا 14
سنه الخدمه اللي خدم فيها هي خدمه تماره
وتكرس اللي كانت موجوده ذاك الزمن هي اللي
كانت كاينه هو شرج الحجار ولا يحفر ولا شذ
الدو الكون غياب الالات الحديثه المتطوره
اللي كاينه ار كي في تراكسات وكيف ال
بوكلان وذا كامل باش يعدلوا المراسي ولا
يعدلوا بنايات ولا الطرقان ولا شدو
عقب ذاك تيسرت الامور وعدد شيفور في واحد
من الكماين ولا الرمك رموك ذاك الزمن ما
هو الرمك الليك رموك زمن فايت كان صيق
راسه
براسه عفوا الرمك اللي الزمن يق راس براسه
بكون التطور اللي فيه والتكنولوجيا
والتقنيات اللي فيه رموك زمن فات كان مش
رويضه ولا رواني قفوت النهار كامل هو خدام
فيه يصلحه غياب النجده ولا اغاثه الطريق
فيها فيها حركه والله
شد عقب ذاك تيسرت الامور وعاد شيفور في
وحده من الشركات اللي معروفه كانت عندنا
هنا في الجهه ومره مره يعيطوا لهم ويقولوا
له لا تمشي تلقى واحد الشخص ولا واحد
السيد اللي جاي في را في المطار وه
الطياره موالفين يشوفو في الجو او مشيت
تلقاو ذاك السيد ويقولهم تدوه الاطيل
الفلاني يش يدو الاطيل عقب ذاك بثلاث ايام
ولا اربعه ويقولهم ذاك الشخص حطيت في
الاوتيل تمش ترد ترد لمطار باش يمشي ويبقى
ذاك التساؤل عندهم دائما هذا الشخص هو منه
هم عارفين عقب ذاك يجي المشرف المباشر
عليهم يقوللهم عاد معان مسؤول على المصلحه
اللي فيها القسم اللي فيها احنا نكم تم
تعرفوا ويمش مجموعه من الرجاله يم يتعرفوا
على هذا
الشخص منين يمش يدخل عليه هذا هو شاب صغير
مصقول نقي لباس زين قاعد ورا
مكتب ويتعرفوا عليه ويعرفو ه السؤال اللي
دور في راسهم شن هو ذا الشاب الصغير يجي
مسؤول عنا الرجاله خلا
هو المقام هو شنو منسول الثاني يقول ذاك
الطفل ولا ذاك الشاب را مهندس مهندس هذ شن
مهندس مسؤول عن القرارات وع الحسابات وع
الاستراتيجيه اللي يعني هذا القسم كامل
شنو خلا يعود مهندس قرا يقولوا به
كرا تخي عقب مده ملي يعيط يقول خصك تمشي
تعدل فيزيت ميديكال ولا تشخيص طبي يمشي
يلتحق بالبارت المسؤول
عنك وجبر طابور طويل فيه الكبير وفيه
الصغير ويقبض نوبته معه يحان تحق نوبته
ويدخل منين يدخل يجبر شابه صغيره بنفس
المواصفات اللي وصت فيها الشاب قويل قعده
و مع مساعدين اثنين ولا
ثلاثه يخطي هو ذك الفيزيت منين يمرق يقول
الخل ذ الطفله فيذا المقام وذا الشان هو
شنو ييقول ذك را طبيبه وكيفاش عا طبيبه
بها جرات ش يفهم هو هو عطات الفرصه يا
يقرا اذا هو ياك يحقق ذاك خص يحق في اقرب
واعز شخص هو منه ولده وله منته يعود هو
دائما يشوف ذاك الشخص يقعد يشوف ولده في
ذاك المكان والله منه في ذاك البلاد
الثاني يعود يمشي ويشارك احلامه يحاول
يحققها في ولده يجينا احنا للدار وجيان
صغير في خلال جلساتنا الليليه ويقوللي
ولدي اقرا باش تعود كيفت فلان اقرا يا
ولدي تعد كيف فلان انا ذاك الساعه ك
الساعه ذاك المهندس و احنا ما نعرفوه
ياغير هو يقوللي اقرا باش تعد كيف فلان
يسمي
لسم تم النبت منين شافينا احنا عننا قبال
عندنا متمسكين بالفكره حتى هو عاد مش مع
ذاك الحلم مشرك معنا ذاك الطموح وصل لدرجه
انه عادين قالنا عملنا ما نتغدا ولا نتعشا
رايتكم هي الاولى المصطلح انا ماس العباره
عند والدي كان دائما يقولها غد وتعش قراكم
هي الاول لدرجه انهم دخلوا معايا في الحلم
اللي كنت باغي عاد يحقق الحلم الثاني انا
يل عنه حلمهم هما وهما يل عنه حلمي
انا وصلت لدرجه انه احيانا نعود مار عندي
فرض عندي فرض منين نرجع سولوني عن شنبك عن
الفرض شنبك مع الفرض نفقع نفقع لاني والفت
داومت معهم
نفقع هذا كامل عنه تم ذاك الشخص قدوه لي
هي قدوه محليه نقدوا
نسموها تم معيا وان ما قطيت ريتو ولا قطيت
شته الى عقب 12 عام من قرايتي اللي هو في
التعليم الاساسي عقب التحقت باقسام
تحضيريه حدني تحت الفرصه ان لقيت معه الا
فرصه وصدفه اصلا معنى ذا كامل
بغيت نقوللكم عنه بذك الجلسه اليوميه
الاسريه تخلي الطفل يتقرب الوالدين ونفس
الحاله الوالدين يتاثر الطفل في اختيار
القدوه المناسبه له هو يطر طفل في اختيار
القدوه المناسبه له هو حاليا عندنا غياب
الظاهره رك كلها عنده قدوه تخيليه ولاق
نقول عنها مصطنعه دار هو استعمال هواتف
ولا هذ افه اللي دخلت عندنا ضرك احنا ما
نقدوا نقولوا عنها افه بذا المعنى ولكن
بما انها دمرتنا ب الطريقه نقدوا نسمو
فيذا الجانب عنها اف عادت حق بعد احنا في
زمن السرعه وتكنولوجيا وذكاء الاصطناعي يا
غير هذا ما يعني انه يقد ي جردنا من
المسائل اللي تقد تزيد
القدام اللي بغيت نقول هو
لاتنا
نرجعوا الجلسه اليوميه الاسريه مع اهلنا
يا كطر تركتنا واولادنا في اختيارهم
مستقبلهم والاختيار صحيح لانه البو ولا
الام عاشوا اكثر وشافوا اكثر المجتمع اللي
كاين فيه احنا وشايفين الانسب تركته لانهم
دائما يخت يعودوا اشبه منهم هما واشبه من
انتاجهم النقطه الثانيه نبغو نحافظوا
عليها ما نسترجع نحافظ عليها والنقطه
الثالثه بغيت ناكد عليها هي ان نقن من
استعمال الهاتف النقال نقن من استعماله
لانه في نهايه المطاف احنا ما يمكننا
كاملين نعود فنانين وما يمكننا كاملين
نعود
تجار الكترونيين ولا رقميين ولا يمكننا
كاملين نعود لعبين الكره را مطلوب عنده
مهندس ومطلوب الطبيب ومطلوب المحامي
ومطلوب الاستاذ ومطلوب النجار ومطلوب
الجزار مطلوبين هذ كاملين مطلوبين في
مجتمعنا وكل واحد منهم راه قدوه عند واحد
ينا نحافظوا ونتمسك بذا ياك نزيدوا لقدام
مجتمعنا
شكرا جزيلا
[تصفيق]
لكم